let me ask you about
the the millions of objects that are
part of the kuiper belt and the part of
the ore cloud
do you think some of them have primitive
life
it kind of makes you sad if there's like
primitive life there and they're just
kind of like lonely out there in space
like how many of them do you think have
life like bacterial life
probably a negligible amount zero you
know like
zero was like a plus on top uh right
plus plus
yeah um
if so you know if you and i took a
little trip
to the interstellar medium i think we
would develop cancer
and die uh real fast right that's rough
yeah it's a pretty hostile radiation
environment
um you don't actually have to go to the
interstellar medium you just have to
leave the earth's magnetic field too
and then you're not doing so well
suddenly
so you know this this idea of
you know life kind of traveling between
places it's not
it's not entirely implausible but you
you really have to
twist i think a lot of parameters one of
the problems we have is we don't
actually know
how life originates right so it's kind
of a
second order question of survival
in the interstellar medium and how
resilient it is because
we we think you require water
but and that's certainly the case for
the earth
but you know we uh we really don't know
for sure
that said i will argue that the question
of like
are there aliens out there is a very
boring question
because the answer is of course there
are right i mean
like we know that
there are planets around almost every
star
um of course there of course there are
other life forms
life is not some specific thing that
happened on the earth and that's it
right
just that's a statistical impossibility
yeah um
yeah but the the difficult question is
before even
the fact that we don't know how life
originates i don't think we even know
what life
is like definitionally yeah like
formalizing a kind of picture
of in terms of the mechanism we would
use to
to search for life out there or even
when we're on a planet
to say is this life is this rock that
just moved
from where it was yesterday life or or
maybe not even rock something else
i got to tell you i want to know what
life is
okay and i want you to show me
uh i think there's a song to basically
accompany every single
thing we talk about today and probably
uh half of them are love songs
um and somehow we'll integrate george
michael into the whole thing okay
so your intuition is there's life
everywhere in our universe
do you think there's intelligent life
out there i think it's entirely
plausible i mean i
it's entirely plausible um
i think i think there's intelligent life
on earth
um and so yeah taking that like say
whatever
this thing we got on earth well there's
dolphins or humans
say that's intelligent definitely
dolphins
i mean have you seen the dolphins
well they do some cruel stuff to each
other so if cruelty
is uh is the definition of intelligence
that they're pretty good yeah and then
humans are pretty good on that
uh regard and then there's like uh
pigs are very intelligent i got i got
actually a chance to hang out with pigs
recently
and they're um aside from the fact
they're trying to
eat me they're very uh
they're very they love food they love
food but there's an intelligence to
their eyes that was kind of
uh like haunts me because i also
love to eat meat and then to to me the
thing
i later ate and that was very
intelligent
and almost charismatic with the way it
was expressing
himself herself itself was uh was quite
incredible
you